Speaker 1: We have now a little bit of data to
maybe answer the question Could disproportionate
Republican COVID deaths have flipped any
particular seats in the 2022 midterms? Now,
let me reset this for you, because we've
talked about this probably for a year or more,
but now we're really in the thick of it because
we now have most of the results of the 2022
midterms. We know that more Republicans than
Democrats died of COVID. We don't know exactly
to what degree or by how much, but we know that
this is a result of. Early on in the pandemic,
Republicans were less likely to heed public
safety guidelines than were Democrats. Therefore,
they got more COVID, and as a function of that,
more of them died in the Post-Vaccine era. Uptake
of vaccines was lower among Republicans than it
was among Democrats. And as a result of that, more
Republicans died of COVID, generally speaking.
And so the question of whether this impacted
the election results is really a mathematical
question. First, you've got to figure out to
what degree were Republicans dying of COVID more
than Democrats? It seems like now it's twice as
much. So we could call it 2 to 1. You could zoom
out and say, okay, twice as much means roughly
two thirds of the COVID deaths were Republicans.
One third of the COVID deaths were Democrats. Got
about a million deaths. Okay. So again, we're
very much zooming out. When a 12 year old dies,
you don't assign a party affiliation to that.
Right. But we're speaking super generally
out of a million. You would say, well, that's
like 666,000 Republican deaths, 333,000 Democratic
deaths. Again, these aren't real numbers because
you've also got nonvoters in there, in kids,
etc.. That means that the gap means about
333,000 more Republicans than Democrats died.
Assuming everybody is a voter and is an
adult. So then you've got to figure out
of that 333,000 gap. Are there any particular
districts where the gap alone or any particular
states for statewide Senate and gubernatorial
elections where that depth difference alone could
have flipped a seat? We don't really know the
answer yet, but it's increasingly being studied.
We there is a well, actually Vice wrote this up
and they are not the authors of the study, but
we'll link to this article. The study is called
Excess Death Rates for Republicans and Democrats
during the COVID 19 pandemic. And they looked at
death records. They looked at voter registration
and they said, what is the link here between
political affiliation, COVID deaths and the impact
on the midterms? Now, I am going to come out and
right upfront say a couple of different things.
It is completely possible that the margins
here were between Republican and Democratic
deaths. In particular, congressional districts,
for example, weren't actually big enough to
really flip any elections. Maybe they were.
Maybe they were not. There are some who are
saying that it is just filthy to even be asking
this question. I completely disagree with that.
You're not making light of anything by on top of
all of the obvious personal and family tragedy
that are COVID deaths. To ask the political
question and say, could this have shaped the
electorate in 2022, it's a completely reasonable
question to ask. So don't don't be swayed by the
Republicans who are turning up their noses and
saying how offensive, how offensive to even ask
the question. There is really nothing wrong with
asking the question. The next part of this is it
would be interesting to actually get some some
specific numbers. You know, we in the lead up
to 2022, I used an example from Florida's last
gubernatorial election. And in Florida's last
gubernatorial election, the margin between Ron
DeSantis and then Democratic candidate Andrew
Gillum was very small. And based on that margin,
the disproportionate Republican COVID deaths in
Florida could have made a difference. But that
was in the last election. The margin was so
big in DeSantis defeating Charlie Crist last week
that the COVID deaths would not make a difference.
It was a 19 point win for Ron DeSantis. So the
theoretical example I gave about Florida from the
previous election, it really doesn't apply because
the margin was so big. So generally speaking,
even if there were no specific races that
depended on the Partizan split in COVID deaths,
this may become a larger component of Republican
demographics related to vaccines beyond COVID.
Given the growing anti-vaccine sentiment that
has developed in the Republican Party since
COVID. More broadly, we might actually start to
see this, particularly over time, be a factor.
We know we've said before there are demographic
changes happening in Texas where Texas is becoming
bluer as a result of demographic changes. There
may also be changes to the electorate forced in
by anti-vaccine sentiment. It shouldn't come as
a huge shock that this is sort of the conclusion
to what has been, quite frankly, decades of
Republicans increasingly denying science,
increasingly telling themselves scientists are
just sort of like liberal professors. You can
ignore everything they say and bring your own
opinion, and your own opinion is just as valid
as theirs. Seeing that grow for decades should
then not make us surprised now at what we are
seeing. At some point we will probably get a
more specific answer. Was there any particular
race that arguably was flipped by disproportionate
Republican COVID deaths? We don't have the answer
right now, but it is being studied. The David
Pakman Show is an audience supported program.
We do an extra show every single day called The
Bonus Show just for our members. We also provide
an audio and video feed of every show Commercial
Free, published about five or 6 hours before the
entire show is published. You can get access to
all of that at join Packman dot com and you can
also use the coupon code 24 starts now to get
yourself a nice little discount that's all at
join Packman dot com. I would love for you
to sign up and support the work that we do.